no it's a red red black red black red
black red black okay this is gonna be
bad yeah do I lose hey what's up this
destiny I'm Blake my name is Lilian and
today I'm gonna be representing the
women okay we're testin who's got the
best memory I fully admit and understand
that meaner trash I don't want to make
women look bad oh wait it's not a
problem
this isn't a problem so we're gambling
not quite good guy right right today
we're testing your memory versus the
lady using four rows of cards the first
rose color second is number heritage
suit but as you go from line to line
you'll need to remember all the previous
lines before it if you get stuck along
the way you'll have one lifeline where
you'll get between 0 & 2 cards you can
flip over oh yeah forgot to mention the
last role you have to remember
everything about the cars colored number
and suit and then everything wait wait
wait no no no I don't understand oh no
tell me wait I don't understand what you
just said so it's just gonna keep
stacking can I pretend I didn't sign up
for this
just the colored not anything else okay
red red black red black red black red
black I'm just gonna like commit this
and burn it into my mind I'm confident
I'm copying the colors red red black red
black starting strong starting strong I
don't think they're gonna be that easy
knows easy get out of here I see what
we're doing here
I see see what you're doing here red red
black red black
color yes no number oh the number okay
this is a joker that's not a member to
five Jack it's five of my my hand has
five fingers okay these aren't numbers
[Music]
all right I'm ready okay
Joker to five decades Joker to five
Japanese got it I got it this is now
that I'm doing it it's easy Joker to 5%
five fingers and this one okay one of
these is a 10 of the other ones a jack I
think this one's the jack
aw nice Queen Jack and ace yay okay
going on oh I should have used the light
line it just seems like a prop oh yeah
this is good okay this is okay this is
really really fun now I'm in Krenzel at
this this is now gonna be harder top it
is ladies this was like a fluke and then
here is when I crumble either fancy cars
can I thank you authorities are it's
very hard hard diamond hard spade a hard
time it's hard to say huh right now
State heart heart diamond heart spade
heart heart diamond I'm gonna get a song
I can remember this because there are
two hearts right here so boom boom heart
heart mm-hmm a diamond say diamond uh
[Music]
red red black red red
Joker to five Jack five
take it to 35 Jack bass parts
let's give this one part Spade heart
heart diamond I got three rows except
for that you pesky little Jack I just
screwed up here because I was trying to
go too fast oh okay
I got him off this I was nervous
I'm not gonna lie but I'm holding it
together for y'all where did you get
these cars man they've dough black
through Red's for 3 for 17 yeah I mean
if it's a heart it's right if it's a
spade it's black you play cards you know
what do you call this one again club I
was like clover that's not right okay
my gosh
I don't feel good about this last row
man this is gonna be bad
geez this seems like a long time from
now
[Music]
black I mean red no red black red black
Joker to 5/8 do I lose eight this is the
this okay this is I'm drawing a complete
blank guys I'm doing bad y'all put the
pressure on me what's going on now I'm
gonna use this little thingy
Oh ready oh yeah come on man
or it's spades I like that these are go
home these look nice this one's a heart
doesn't that hurt yes okay a heart I
remember there were three hearts okay
okay
diamond I just needed that I just needed
that first little that a little bit all
right
my wife won't need it whole new it fun
three red hearts no dang gosh four of
diamonds no I'm gonna say seven of
spades for diamond using my lifeline
I got blue which means I can flip over
two cards though I'm flipping over these
things I don't know what they're this is
a red two of Hearts no it's a seven of
Hearts red I'm gonna go with the 7 of
spades 7 of cartoon and then this is 7
of Black Spades no it's a 4 okay King of
Diamonds because kod this is a strip
club in Atlanta
[Music]
but you know what I did a good job and I
may be crazy so one more time heart no
wait what was it hot I know the one
we're gonna come in here we're gonna
handle their business okay they can do
what they have to do because that's what
we do in life we do what we have to do
to get the job done just from my
experience with women they're gonna
remember women we are amazing we are
strong we can remember things it's okay
you know everyone has their strengths
you guys maybe we'll win something else
we can't
[Music]